our habitual failure to recognize
thought as thought our habitual
identification with discursive thought
is a primary source of human suffering
and when a person breaks this spell an
extraordinary kind of relief is
available Buddha or Jesus may have
experienced in his life so apart from
just commending these phenomenon to your
attention I want to say that that our
neglect of these phenomenon as atheists
puts us at a rhetorical disadvantage
because millions of people have had
these experiences and many millions more
have had glimmers of them and and these
are these experiences are often the most
important and transformative moments in
their lives and when if we by definition
ignore them because of their
entanglement with religion
we appear less wise than even our
craziest religious opponents now I don't
know if if the universe is as JBS
Haldane said not only stranger than we
suppose but stranger than we can suppose
but I'm pretty sure that it is stranger
than we as atheists tend to represent
while advocating atheism may as a theist
we tend to give people a sense and even
give ourselves a sense that we are well
on our way to purging the universe of
mystery as advocates of reason we know
that mystery is going to be with us for
quite some time in fact there are good
reasons to believe that mystery may be
in eradicable from our circumstance with
it because what however much we
understand the universe it seems like
there could well always be brute facts
which we can't explain but which we must
use to explain everything else now this
is not a problem for human life it is
not a barrier to human happiness but so
but we are faced with the the task of
convincing a myth infatuated world that
love and curiosity are sufficient and
that you don't have to delude yourself
and frighten yourself with iron-age
fairy tales
this is this is a monumental task I
don't think there's any intellectual
struggle more worthy of our efforts this
is a future absolutely worth fighting
for I think it may in fact be the only
future compatible with our survival as a
species I mean that and we this will be
a world simply where people cease to
pray as one another for believing things
or pretending to believe things for
which they have no evidence but the only
path between now and them that I can see
is for us to be unremittingly honest and
to advocate intellectual honesty and it
seems to me the intellectual honesty
will always be more durable and deeper
and more easily spread than atheism
what are you talking about you're
embarrassing your movement you're not
talking about the cold-hard reduction is
scientific materialistic naturalistic
point of view you now slowly using a bit
of technical jargon a bit of rhetoric a
bit of semantics whereas office to tryna
see it a little bit of spirituality into
your little movement on you because you
realize it's gonna fail without it
because the essence of human beings is
we're not just physical because if we
were we would be doing what Darwin's
what Richard Dawkins says the highest
rationale of our existence is the
preservation of our genes that's how we
should behaving that's how you should
act don't start acting like us because
if you start acting like us well firstly
it shows you in fur algae complex and
secondly it just shows that your
worldview is actually undermined by the
behavior of human beings which is to
collect with a higher spiritual power so
while I go off and pray why don't you go
do some reproduction